>>When I came here, the school was
-- had a very discouraged faculty.
There was a lot of
student-to-student violence.
It was highly tracked, we
had seven different tracks,
so that's seven different segregated
groups that moved throughout the day.
So that caused a lot of the
animosity between student groups,
because some groups were
frankly treated a lot better
than other groups.
And the groups were right
along socioeconomic lines,
and racial lines.
So when I first took over here, I
knew that something had to change.
>>The work with the staff begin
with an investigation of the idea
of Outward Bound, and could you
upset the ruts of, you know,
traditional thinking by getting
people out of the building
and on an Outward Bound course,
and so that's where I
started, and I got...
The first time we had just five
people, and myself, six of us,
went on an outward bound
course, and we began realizing
that somehow we had to
bring this back to school,
somehow the teamwork really
worked in the wilderness,
could it work in the school?
We really learned well
when we were up there.
Could you take that learning and
bring it inside the school building?
The idea of Outward Bound is
not to get yourself to the top
of the mountain, but to get
everyone to the top of the mountain,
and that really has been the
philosophy of this school.
We have a lot of needy kids.
How do you -- how do you
create school experiences
that work for all kids?
How do you create a culture of
school, where every kid matters,
and those are the values that we,
sort of, planned the school on.
So if you have those values,
how do you operationalize them,
and if you stack -- so we started
looking at, who is learning here,
and we found that we were running
two schools, one for the haves,
and one for the have nots.
So the change we made there
is, we eliminated tracking.
And when you eliminate tracking
and, you know, people --
teachers are used to
teaching a certain way,
you also had to change the
way learning was delivered.
So all of the research we found
was that kids working in teams,
kids working on project based
learning, really worked.
>>I decided to create a leadership
team, which was representative
of teachers from all over the school.
Some who were in agreement with
what we were doing, and some not.
And I presented these ideas
about changing the schedule
and eliminating tracking, and
could we be about a school that...
Could we be...
Run a school that valued all kids,
and try to create some teacher time
to work together, so more
of a collaborative culture.
And the leadership team, we sort
of worked together, and we --
and we came to agreement
on that vision.
And then we brought it
to the rest of the staff,
and we've moved on from there.
We created teams of teachers to work
on, what does a schedule looks like,
where teachers own time, and
that was one of the first steps.
And how do you teach to a variance
in classrooms, and that became
when we -- that's how we
investigated expeditionary learning.
>>The staff has a lot
of autonomy here.
They have control of time,
they make their own schedules,
they make their own decisions about
what expeditions they're going to do.
We -- my job is to support them in
any way they can, and to protect them
and to make sure that
they have the resources.
The protection part is, you know,
sometimes we're out on a limb,
and we're doing some things that are
maybe riskier than normal school,
and we all know that the only way you
learn is through taking some risks.
>>The major part of our assessment
here is the quality of student work.
Every -- every expedition
kid produces several items,
but there's usually a final product
that I would match that quality
of work up with any
school in the country.
So you have that.
The students also maintain
a portfolio of their work,
which they present to their
parents two times a year,
and so that they know that their
work has to be of high quality,
because they're presenting it.
It's not about the parent coming in
asking the teacher how they're doing,
the student has to
present their work.
So that's, I think, the
most important thing,
but we also have state
standardized tests at King,
just like everybody else
does in the country.
And the -- and for our kids at King,
even though 56 percent of them are
on free lunch, and 33 percent of
them are second language learners,
and we speak 31 different languages,
we score above the state average
in every curriculum area,
at every grade level.
>>We have people who have come from,
I think there's 16 foreign countries
to come and see how we use laptops,
and then, when they come here,
they see the laptops, they say,
"Well you also have this thing
called expeditionary learning,
and project based learning.
If we just had that, and
laptops, we could do this,
but we don't have expeditionary
learning, we're just going
to buy laptops," and
then we have people
from expeditionary learning come, who
are investigating whether they want
to do it, and they look
at expeditionary learning,
and they said, "Well we
can't possibly do that,
because we don't have the laptops."
>>But what we say, it's all
about engagement of kids,
whether you have the laptops,
or whether you have...
The design of the school is, we
get kids excited about learning,
and we let them go, and they
-- and the, you know, the --
really the genius of this
school is not in a program,
it's not in the laptops,
it's in the learning,
it's in teachers designing learning
that they know will work for kids.
And it's not a program, it's not
a laptop, it's the whole thing,
it's about, they value kids,
they know how to engage them,
and they have the space and the
time and the autonomy to do it.
>> For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org